le vieux montréal est populaire auprès
des touristes
c'est ici que l'on retrouve des plus
fortes concentrations d'appartements à
louer ce rallye nbi dans tout le canada
une résidence sur 15 est sur orbite be
et c'est la même chose au centre-ville
et sur le plateau autour du carré saint
louis
la ville de montréal est bien au courant
de cette réalité il faut envoyer un
message fort que ce n'est pas acceptable
que des logements soient pris en otage
alan est long pour faire d'allocations
abbiati nous avons compté seulement pour
montréal
pas moins de neuf mille sept cents us
annonce airbnb pour des logements en
entier ça représente 1% de toutes les
résidences de la ville mais presque
toutes les annonceurs bienne be sont
concentrés dans deux arrondissements
ville-marie qui comprend le
vieux-montréal et centre-ville et le
plateau mont royal dans les quartiers
comme au carré saint-louis et
regroupements de locataires estiment que
la location de type airbnb alimente la
pénurie de logements ça fait deux ans et
demi aussi quand des noms ce phénomène
qu'on écrit que c'est alarmant mais
qu'est ce qui est permis et qu'est ce
qui ne l'est pas si vous louez au moins
deux pas de problème si vous offrez
votre résidence principale pour quelques
nuits une ou deux fois dans l'année
ça aussi c'est permis par contre selon
la réglementation actuelle si l'offre
est pour du court terme pour moins de 31
jours et que vous louez sur une base
régulière constante fréquentes ou
récurrente et ça devient une résidence
de tourisme et pour ça il faut
absolument détenir une attestation de
classification mais comment déterminer
si un logement est loué sur une base
régulière
après une visite un bienne be vous
propose de commenter votre séjour
logiquement plus lieu de commentaires
plus l'appartement et visiter
régulièrement on aussi blanc que les
annonces qui avaient plusieurs dizaines
de commentaires eh bien on a recensé
seulement dans l'arrondissement ville
marie entre sept et huit cents
appartements qui sont loués
régulièrement ont officiellement il n'y
a que 26 attestation pour résidence de
touristes
dans ce secteur comme on veut mais c'est
du commercial en milieu résidentiel
c'est pas des personnes qui veulent
arrondir leurs fins de mois qui font ça
c'est des spéculateurs c'est des
locateurs immobilier qui font de
l'argent sur le dos des raisins
résidente dans l'histoire citoyenne qui
habitent les villes entre sept et huit
cents potentiel résidence de touristes
et bien c'est l'équivalent de quatre
hôtels de taille moyenne comme celui-ci
et l'association des hôteliers de
montréal parle de concurrence déloyale
il s'agit de plusieurs centaines d'
inutile voire quelques milliers ce mot
rien donc l'équivalent de quelques
grands hôtels qui sont qui sont en
mesure d'offrir sans taxes sans impôt
sans taxes foncières commerciales des
incas d'hébergement depuis 2018
l'arrondissement ville-marie limite les
nouvelles résidences de tourisme à la
rue sainte catherine
mais quand on peut le voir sur cette
carte presque tous les appartements que
nous avons identifiés sont hors de cette
zone
mon problème actuellement c'est que le
gréement du québec doit s'en mêler et
est beaucoup plus proactifs
on a le ministère du revenu maintenant
qu'ils peuvent donner des amendes très
salée force est d'admettre que sur le
terrain ça s'est pas encore manifestée
le problème c'est que la réglementation
actuelle est tellement floue que ça
devient difficile de donner des
contraventions
une situation que prévoit clarifier la
nouvelle ministre du tourisme
raison pour laquelle avant la fin de la
présente session parlementaire
je vais déposer un règlement donc un
règlement qui va être clair qui va être
simple qui va être applicable mais
surtout qu'il est équitable pour tout le
monde de son côté un regain de vie
affirme simplement être favorable à une
réglementation
pourvu que les règles soient
intelligente et qu'elle réponde aux
attentes des gens
[Musique]